hey guys it's Tuesday I'm Justin if
you've been wondering what's going on in
video games you have come to the right
place here's what's going on first up a
new teaser site from Sega has suggested
that something Bayonetta related might
be coming our way the site features only
a countdown that's currently sitting at
around six days as for why people are
assuming this could be Bane at a news
the characters foot can be seen in the
dimly lit background behind the
countdown the head of the site simply
reads coming soon on April Fool's Day
Sega released an 8-bit version of
bayonetta for free on Steam so maybe
that one had a bit more substance than
we originally thought the last entry in
the series was 2014 Spain a tattoo and
last year at e3 designer Hideki Kamiya
said he'd been thinking a lot about
being at a three please leave your
speculation in the comment box next up a
pile of classic jak and daxter games I
headed to ps4 sony has announced that
jak and daxter the precursor legacy jak
2 and jak 3 are joining the ps2 on ps4
game library later this year if that's
still not enough Jack for you jack x
combat racing is slated to arrive on ps4
sometime next year like other ps2 on ps4
games and these will be upscaled to
1080p and include trophies you'll also
be able to use features like share play
and remote play we don't have any extra
news on pricing or release dates just
yet but stay tuned the ps2 on ps4
library now includes 40 titles including
red dead revolver psychonauts and GTA
san andreas finally Bioware has
announced a weighty patch for Mass
Effect Andromeda this should address a
handful of your concerns available on
april six the patch includes technical
fixes as well as a number of
improvements such as the ability to skip
the brutally long transition animations
that play when you're venturing between
planets and alterations that boost the
appearance of eyes for human and asari
characters decryption keys which are
used to bypass the game sodoku s
well costs left to purchase and will be
more readily available the patch is also
improving localized voiceover lip sync
and tweaking riders movement when
running in a zigzag Patten you can check
out the full patch notes in our story on
game [ __ ] Iowa have said they will be
rolling out additional patches that will
go even deeper and look to improve
things like the character crater the
general appearance of characters and
cinematics among other things that is
everything I got for you today do let me
know what you thought of today's stories
be sure to hit that subscribe button if
you liked today's video and I will see
you again to our